season is the fourth time that beveling  has found out now that he's being  ushered back to the dressing room is he  hit with the tea and westbrook's has got  hit the cheating kicked out as well  that's so hard he shoving him away  doesn't want him to get involved even  more he's a little upset with this but  with your fifth foul you you cannot  reach in like that Beverly is smarter  than that he understands that when he  watched tape but the argument between  the two guys  Westbrook waves Adam says where are you  now and let's remember the histories  Beverly played to the end of a play in  Oklahoma City  Westbrook hurt his knee on that plane  did not return these two have always had  a little bit of extra curricular exit